you're a badass dude you don't even know
how many times i saw the star trek
movies when you were [ __ ] in the
remember you guys
remember
no no no remember
i always said you weren't you guys were
both shooting down you and kirk shooting
down to think sh right and they were
drilling right the red stuff the matter
right yeah and then you
you put your parachute
right and then
you landed on it i remember he was
slipping ah right and you had your sword
and then they came out of the little
little compartment you fought him like
this can
i i want you to do another an entirely
new podcast
where you just describe movies
i i should it would be a hit it was it's
like audio books yeah you know what i
mean but there's another star trek when
you were um you were you were told to
lead you were you're you're the captain
right remember yeah and then you had to
do that one speech yeah
i remember that too here's another thing
in the third movie right you're just
telling him no i'm gonna tell you but
you were so athletic oh it was basically
the whole time
how that's left right and then the third
movie i remember remember you were
captured on that uh
in that
you know on that planet right and then
that lady had that thing in her head
remember she had the
thing that opens up
you were there right yeah yeah yeah and
here's what i also liked about the movie
they made because of um sulu they they
made your character
gay i like that
i love you know what i remember um
uh i just remember uh
there were there were um there were
discussions about sulu's husband
and um i i
i said uh because because it could have
been a different species could have been
a klingon or whatever yeah yeah yeah and
i said i i was like an asian man
uh and
there was a little bit of difficulty
because we were shooting that scene in
dubai and there were
cultural problems with cast
getting an east asian man
and one that would be willing to be
depicted as gay wow
so we ended up using
our one of our screenwriters for that
role
but um but i requested an asian man
because i was like if we're gonna go
gay and this is just my own trip i was
like i wanted to be super
uh like
heteronormative
in the future like this is
so there's no like a weirdness about
because i did know like being older i've
known a lot of gay asian dudes who don't
want to touch asian dudes
oh you know wow and so i was like i want
that in the future there there's no
hang-ups this dude's thinking about the
[ __ ] future over here
bro what if you got a call to be his
husband but
when i saw that i've seen that movie
thousand times but when i saw that part
every time i see that part i go
imagine
i meant because
pike what's his name chris pike
christmas pine crystal pine christopher
captain
what's his name christopher chris pine
christopher
major
i love him
i love him right
but there was a moment where he gets off
the ship he sees you guys and you guys
walk up with your daughter right yeah
right yeah imagine if just for a split
second if it was me
and now the audience did the audience
imagine the audience they would go
[ __ ]
crazy
the
it would have ruined the movie
you would have ruined the movie but it
would have been it would have been a
great
piece of cast but dude i'm telling you
right now
[Laughter]
honestly i love
i'm a big star trek fan bro and i love
those movies oh thanks yeah
i'm gonna stop fanboying dude yeah so
how did you get into star trek
because i wanted to put you down a
little bit
a little bit just a little bit you know
what i mean
i'll tell you how dude
uh yeah go ahead
i'll tell you how dude [ __ ] dude
can i tell you how to do it all right
because i don't think that i
loved living
my life i love my life but it's like the
society i live in i don't particularly
like you know i mean it's free i have
the freedom i love being an american but
because of all the stuff that we've
talked about right i think as a kid i've
always wanted to see a different future
you know i mean and
star trek always
provided a future for me that i could
live with
like for instance
multicultural right there's no there's
no you're talking about the original
series right no i'm talking about next
generation next generation okay i'm a
big next generation i like the original
as well
but um the next generation it's all
about just growing and helping each
other i don't know i just
glommed on to that idea right that we
could all just kind of move beyond
this trump [ __ ] all the [ __ ] that we had
it's backwards i i i have the same
feeling about star trek and it is like
it was born in the 60s
and
it was this vision
of post-war america like we could be the
city on the hill we could be a great
nation
you know and we're going to be diverse
and obviously there
it's of its era so there's a white man
at the helm but like it was this really
inclusive
uh idea of what america could be because
it's it's said in space but it's about
america and what
we
what we could be if we really stuck to
our ideals or rather lived up to our
stated ideals yeah you know
it's so also important
to see people like sulu and ura i'm
saying that right
right please like korean word i just try
my best guys
all right so to see an aging you know i
think check off what's chekhov mexican
what is he russia
check out steam's mexican yeah
is he russian russian yeah
it's just all that stuff
what's so funny
that you got the original chekhov looks
mexican like if he doesn't no i mean if
you honestly dude if you went to i don't
want to be stereotypical but
keto moss
i don't know
i'm sorry let's just move on
i think i took myself a hole dude yeah i
think i took myself keep it in but you
know what i mean chikov's not mexican
let's move on don't have to look it up i
don't know what you're doing i just want
to make sure um
but i'm sorry also i want to say i made
sure we brought it up sorry for your
loss on that movie maybe spanish
yeah that must have been devastating was
that devastating obviously i don't want
to talk about it yeah it was uh
he uh
uh anton uh
uh
this is just uh a really special person
and um
um part of i'm sure part of
uh
what makes it extra
uh he he's a really beautiful person and
um
he was just young
and um so
you um tell he's so talented oh my god
um
you know like i don't consider myself a
natural born actor like i go oh i had to
learn how to do that and
uh i'm i'm clever you know what i mean
like i figured it out you're crafty i'm
crafty
but uh
but like he's a natural born
artist i i won't even say actor he was
just like oh this this is a seeker he's
um
uh well to get that part right though
right because they're so iconic these
parts right he doesn't look like chekov
right
it's he became him val yeah which is the
is which convinced me like as soon as he
started talking i'm like yep that's
check off yeah even though he didn't
have the look yeah a huge a huge fan you
know um
that's a really good cast all around us
oh my god dude what it's a [ __ ]
i'm sorry i'm getting goosebumps right
now dude
that whole series dude
is amazing are you not doing more
i don't know um we might um
they're so good yeah i think so is it
because i mean it would be hard to move
on
i think there's a lot of elements in why
it's been
hard to do and part of it is
just
everyone
it is really busy like that's a big cast
and everyone kind of
uh i don't want to i don't want to sound
like i'm too everyone kind of his car
their careers grew and killing it
they're they're so there's that and um
you know i don't know uh if we're
but i'm also not sure sometimes like are
we
competing with
giant franchises like
like billion dollar franchises avengers
you mean yeah and that kind of thing and
we're actually more niche than that you
know really the the the i think star
trek movies are not that they're
at its core they're
rather intellectual you know what i mean
they're not action movies as such
um and so i don't think you can expect
but but and yet they're expensive
you know like those other movies so it's
it's sort of
i don't know yeah that's a shame because
i i could literally watch another nine
of those movies
i mean you watch me i i'll watch that
[ __ ] over over and over and over again
i'm obsessed with it i really think that
they're that good mm-hmm yeah i think i
love jj abrams i i love you i love
what's his name christopher pine
christopher pine chris pine where's mine
yeah his dad's right yeah his dad was in
the uh weird that you know who his dad
is and you i know this is my comment
chris
john john i just want to say something
to you bud
bob pine uh in chips yes yes he was
amazing chips chips did you meet him
yeah
yeah you did yeah he's a gentleman ipad
he's like a proper
proper gentleman let me ask you
is this something
i want a little insight okay
what's leonard nimoy like
like um
he's like a spirit not like a human
being like he's he's uh was um
uh like
just a beautiful spirit like a almost um
kind of like a religious figure
maybe that's all he's an angel angel
yeah he is yeah angel straight from
heaven yeah it's a beautiful person well
i didn't know him well i can just say
who does
who knew that
right but i remember there was a scene
where they were doing it with chris pine
and um
who's the englishman i like
benedict cumberbatch
no no no the other one the funny one
scotty peg simon pegg
love simon pegg i was in paul oh yeah
one line you got cut i got cut out of it
simon pegg and chris pine were doing a
scene i guess with leonard nimoy and i
guess leonard nemo was taking a nap
and they were both going holy [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] letter while i was sleeping like
it must have been
so amazing to have someone like that on
set man what it felt like i recall
in the first movie was like it felt
like uh
we were being blessed you know by the by
him agreeing to be in it and it felt
like okay we're going to be all right um
and it because everyone was kind of
nervous and
um
we were wondering whether this is the
right thing and all this stuff and are
we gonna make a good movie and are the
fans gonna like and all the stuff and
leonard nimoy just walked on the set and
he was
very calm and very sweet
and very complimentary and i think
everyone exhaled
when he showed up
and he was giving that to us i felt like
i
i'm telling you right now man
if i saw leonard nimoy
i think i would just have no more
moisture in my body
because of just the sheer joy of tears
coming down my face
i love him so much that guy i believe
that do you believe that yes i do yeah
i'm [ __ ] obsessed with you
oh my god what a great guy
he paid moistureless when he died
um
i feel like it's been
almost 10 years
it's been that oh wow
could it be
uh 2015.
um wait a minute i'm sorry that's
yeah 2015. wow
so john are you back for a while now or
no yeah i'm back um i i
shot the show in new zealand yeah and
then um
i stayed and did
uh a film there and then um
and then we were there sort of we waited
out the pandemic a little bit put my
kids in school and then um in new
zealand you did yeah